- I have been talking about
Hooters my entire career.
- You just needed the voice,
- Yeah
you just needed the platform of the voice.
- I needed the platform.
I was even a Hooters
waitress, not for real,
for comedy back in the day.
(audience laughs)
I wore the outfit and everything.
Listen they wear pantyhose,
so they are keeping it classy.
(audience laughing)
And they legit (laughs)--
(laughter)
They're classy!
- No way
- No way. They're wearing pantyhose.
- But they're wings are
(smacks lips) so good.
- Their tig old bitties are out,
but the pantyhose, super classy.
- I talk about them in my special
and still there's like, huh?
And so I'm doing whatever I can
to keep Hooters legacy alive.
- We are gonna get this partnership.
- We're do we find this
special, is it up there now?
- Uh, my special in on Netflix right now.
- It's on Netflix?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] She's hilarious.
- I'll look for it
- I would love for you to watch it.
- I'll do it.
- And if you like Hooters,
you might like the show
- I'm gonna do it.
- Good. I know you're
busy, your creating--
(laughter)
- Awesome shows and tv
- Well we can do one together.
- Please.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh please.
- I would love that.
- [Kelly] Can you call it Hooters?
(audience cheers)
- Yes
- It can be about owls, whatever.
- Yeah.
- Do you have any other plans,
like big plans for 2020?
- Oh man, 2020
- Are you gonna get married?
- I am, my fiancee is here
in the audience somewhere.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] Yes, I'm like, where?
- She's over there
- Ah
- Hi Jacqs!
- [Kelly] She's way in the corner
the actual furthest point from us.
(laughter)
- Nobody puts baby in the corner.
- Apparently they do
(laughter)
- So y'all are gonna get married.
- We're gonna get married hopefully,
I mean that's the plan, right?
We're still getting married.
(Kelly laughs)
- You still love me, right?